vielen dank hieraus tier gerade eben
wieder sirenenalarm morgen sind wir
einen monat lang im krieg im krieg gegen
die gesamte ukraine was ich heute erlebt
habe und hier war auf der einen seite
skurril auf der anderen seite etwas was
mich nachhaltig beschäftigt ich war in
einem waffenlager in kiew und habe dort
erstmals man musste lange danach suchen
denn so viele sind ja nicht da deutsche
waffen gefunden eine panzerabwehrwaffe
juli der soldat dort hat mir erklärt die
sei so einfach zu bedienen wie ein
volkswagen man eigne sich das mit
youtube videos an wie man diese
panzerabwehrwaffe bedient aber er hat
auch gesagt wir brauchen dringend mehr
wir brauchen mehr panzerabwehrwaffen wir
brauchen mehr finger wir brauchen etwas
das uns schützt das den himmel schützt
wenn ihr keine flugverbotszone wollt
sagte julie und sagen alle politiker und
menschen hier dann muss deutschland mehr
helfen mehr her schicken und ich kann
dem nur zustimmen
denn das was gerade passiert auch wenn
es so aussieht dass die ukraine momentan
zumindest hier in der hauptstadt ihre
sich gut verteidigen können das kann
jeden tag jede woche jeden monat und
dieser krieg kann monate dauern anders
werden denn wenn man die langfristige
perspektive betrachtet dann ist die
russische armee natürlich überlegen und
wir können es nicht länger aufhalten wir
können nicht länger warten mit dem hin
und her der deutschen bürokratie diese
waffen die ukraine brauchen diese waffen
trinkt jeden tag die sie nicht kommen
jeden tag die wir deutschen auch weiter
zögern kosten hier leben
heute ist wieder eine premiere bei
villach denn jetzt kommt sofort die
these von herr stegner für heute abend
weil paul du und herr stegner hatte
beide das thema mitgebracht heute abend
mit einer völlig komplett anderen
sichtweise es sinn machen wir heute mal
direkt beide thesen hintereinander und
diskutieren dann herr stegner sie können
loslegen wir haben es mit einer
zeitenwende zu tun durch den brutalen
angriffskrieg von putin gegen die
ukraine und anders als putin sich das
erwartet hat hält die nato und den
westen zusammen wir haben gemeinsame
sanktionen beschlossen mit dem ziel ihn
zu isolieren weltweit isolieren der
russischen wirtschaft zu schaden wir
müssen raus aus der energieabhängigkeit
auch dass wir den russen schaden wir
müssen uns selbst stärken mit unserer
eigenen verteidigungsfähigkeiten es tun
wir im sondervermögen die bundeswehr zu
stärken und ja wir haben auch waffen
geliefert aufdruck sozusagen der
internationalen gemeinschaft auch weil
natürlich die ukraine das recht hat sich
selbst zu verteidigen ich würde aber
einwenden dass das auf dauer keine
lösung ist weil ich niemanden kenne der
glaubt dass dieser konflikt militärisch
zu entscheiden ist zugunsten der ukraine
was immer das zugunsten dann auch heißen
mag und weil ich vor allem diejenigen
sehe die keine interviews geben die
nicht über so was reden soll die als
frauen und kinder flüchten hungern kälte
haben tod und verletzungen zerstörung
flucht vertreibung all das hat dem
kriegt es ganz schrecklich und die these
sind schnell waffen das ist der krieg
schneller vorbei das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube wir müssen putin an den
verhandlungstisch zwingen in der tat es
darf kein satelliten start werden aber
krieg ist das furchtbarste was es gibt
und darunter leidet die zivilbevölkerung
auch die jungen soldaten übrigens die
sterben müssen mit 18 19 jahren und das
ist kann sich kaum einer vorstellen dass
wir das haben der krieg muss so schnell
wie möglich beendet werden waffenruhe
und humanitäre hilfe dass die erste
priorität und dann kommt das andere
manch einer der hier davon redet wir
sollten das so machen macht es von
bequemen sessel aus auszubaden hat das
zivilbevölkerung die toten die menschen
die leiden müssen und das sage ich bei
allem respekt vor dem
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine und
natürlich müssen die das selbst
entscheiden aber wir müssen entscheiden
was wir tun und waffenlieferung ist
meiner meinung nach auf dauer nicht der
richtige weg zumal die nato welt der so
sagen darf sich nicht beteiligen darf
wenn sie das nämlich tete mit den
flugverbotszonen dann haben wir
weltkriegs gefahren dass das nicht
ausgedehnt werden da ist vielleicht in
brand versteht sich für mich von selbst
hier steht mir darf ich eine rückfrage
noch kurz an sie stellen sie haben
gerade gesagt die waffen wurden
geliefert von deutschland in die ukraine
auch aufgrund des drucks des
internationalen drucks halten sie diese
waffenlieferung auch für falsch die
bislang schon erfolgt sind ich tue mir
damit wahnsinnig schwer weil ich
meistens glaube dass waffen nicht dazu
beitragen kriege zu beenden sondern sie
zu verlängern und sagte wer dann die
opfer sind aber ich kann das
nachvollziehen dass man in dem moment
sozusagen gemeinsam handeln wollte aber
es ist nicht die richtige lösung weil
ich nicht glaube russland ist die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt ist das
größte land der welt dass das
militärisch gut ausgehen kann und dann
reden leute von stellungskrieg was heißt
ein stellungskrieg das heißt es geht
womöglich wochenlang noch so weiter
kommen sie doch machen dann werden kann
häuser bombardiert da werden da kommen
jeden tag menschen ums leben und das
sind ganz normale menschen alte junge
frauen männer familien und das muss
beendet werden wir versuchen mal einen
logischen bruch in ihrer argumentation
schaffen zu beleuchten
wenn man zu ende denkt was sie sagen
bedeutet das am besten hätte man die
ukraine gleich dem putin übergeben denn
der putin hat ja den krieg begonnen und
die waffen gewählt und wenn man dann
sagt man rüstet dort nicht in gewisser
weise auf und hilft bei der
selbstverteidigung dann bedeutet das ja
zu ende gedacht das land wird untergehen
und kommt an putin und wenn ich dann
ihren zweiten gedanken hinzufügen mit
möglichst wenig zivilen verlusten mit
möglichst wenig toten dann hätte der
erste lynskey vor dreieinhalb wochen
sich mit putin treffen können ihm die
hand geben können und sagen ich gebe
ihnen mein land dann wären niemand
gestorben es werden alle häuser in mario
pohl noch sozusagen in guter kondition
und aggressor hätte gelernt ein
verteidigungs loser westen
ist nicht in der lage mehr widerspruch
das heißt in der konsequenz überhaupt
nicht erstens bin ich kein pazifist ich
weiß sehr genau dass wir die demokratie
in deutschland nur haben weil die
alliierten kriegs vom nazi deutschland
militärisch besiegt haben und das muss
man ich sage nur in einer situation wo
wir zwei prämissen haben die erste ist
die nato greift nicht ein so sagen das
geld und zweitens dass diese überlegene
militär macht von der ukraine nicht
bezogen werden kann auch wenn wir noch
so viele waffen liefern wenn das beides
gilt dann kann man sagen den krieg zu
verlängern heißt mehr zivile opfer zu
haben und wir lieben die atomkraft ihn
als wir machen ja nicht nichts aber weil
ihm gerade weil ihr kanzler genauso
denkt dauert das so lange das sind
2000 folgte die hätten dann auch schon
vor zwei wochen schicken können oder
profi
in die diskussion rein er kann ja nicht
verstecken denn sie sind ja hier in der
poleposition am tisch deswegen paul du
hörst es ja deine meinung zu bisherigen
diskussion
ja ich habe da wir sagen natürlich eine
komplett konträre meinung denn was klaus
sagt also die argumentation von ralf
stegner läuft darauf hinaus dass man
hätte sagen müssen okay wir können uns
nicht wehren ihr seid größer hier ist
unser land und das ist aus mehreren
gründen komplett unrealistisch bei der
trieb nicht nur weil das kein präsident
dieser welt machen könnte sondern auch
weil das volk hier und sie haben es ja
teilweise angesprochen ein widerstand
leistet dem niemand diesem volk
zugetraut hätte und wenn wir uns
anschauen wie auch viele politiker
geredet haben zu beginn dieses krieges
die gesagt haben ja auch jetzt keine
waffen denn in 72 stunden gehört dieses
land ja russland dann muss ich mal die
frage stellen wer sagt denn am ende dass
ein widerstand der ukrainer wenn er so
weiter geht wie in den vergangenen vier
wochen wir müssen uns das ja einmal vor
augen führen ein monat krieg eine große
stadt ist in den händen russlands dieser
krieg ist grausam es gibt wahnsinnig
viele tote und das ist schrecklich ohne
frage aber was putin erreichen wollte
hat er bislang nicht erreicht wer sagt
denn dass
wladimir in zwei monaten in drei monaten
oder wann auch immer seine ziele
erreicht und wirklich diese städte
erobert hat und die taktik der ukraine
das gebe ich jetzt einfach mal wieder
ist zu sagen wir wollen maximale stärke
zeigen maximale stärke beweisen so zu
sagen und dann bei möglichen
verhandlungen denn für die sind die
ukraine ja offen obwohl wladimir putin
ihr land angegriffen hat sagt willi lenz
geht die ganze zeit lasst uns verhandeln
lasst uns an einen tisch sitzen aber
haben uns einen michaela wären sogar
bereit mittlerweile nichts sagen lassen
würde wären sogar bereit
wären eigentlich das dazwischen reden
ist uns meiner aufgabe
die die ukraine werden doch sonst bereit
so zu schon bereit auf die nato
mitgliedschaft zu verzichten werden zu
neutralität bereit diejenigen die zu
nichts bereit sind sind russland wenn
ich dann doch sagen dass ich möchte
schon zurückweisen sie sollten meine
position nicht garantieren ich habe
höchsten respekt vor dem was die ukraine
da tut und die entscheidet es auch
selbst was sie tut wir reden darüber was
wir tun können und wir tun ja nicht
nichts diese sanktionen sowie hier
hatten wir noch nicht haben ja das ziel
den putin zu isolieren möglicherweise um
die finanzbasis zu entziehen ihn zu
zwingen der hat ja nicht gedacht dass
die hirntote nato wie
gesagt dass die zusammen kommt dass der
westen sich so einig wie er es getan hat
putin war davon glaube ich schon
überrascht und die moral seiner truppe
ist schlecht trotzdem kenne ich keinen
militärexperten der sagt dass es ein
erfolg und was ist wenn es erfolg denn
alle städte zerstört sind am ende wenn
wir an dem punkt sind und mein punkt ist
ein anderer nicht dass man die
verteidigungsfähigkeit bestreitet
sondern dass der preis dafür dass wir
das sagen und womöglich waffen liefern
ist das eben ganz viele menschen die
auch im leben haben wollten wir die
nicht sterben wollen die nicht
angehörigen vernehmen die nicht hungern
wollten die nicht traumatisiert sein
wollen das team das alles passiert und
deswegen ist eine krieges verlängerung
für mich für die zivilbevölkerung
jedenfalls und auch für die soldaten
etwas was ihm in meiner verantwortung
nur schwer verwinden kann aber ich man
kann das anders sehen nur ich finde man
sollte nicht die motivation und ich habe
nicht gesagt sie sollen aufgeben und
putin das land übergeben sondern putin
ist ein kriegsverbrecher er muss
irgendwann auch vor gericht stellt wenn
du musst jetzt gehindert werden
möglichst das weiter zu tun was er will
das ist meine position als jemand die
kriege erlebt hat und nach deutschland
eigentlich eine besseres und sicher das
leben gesucht hat gar nicht ihre
motivation sehr gut nachvollziehen ich
will auch nicht dass diese krieg sondern
flächendeckend der krieg werd ich kann
und schätze auch diese bemühungen auch
von deutschland was ich nicht verstehe
wenn wir sagen dass die ukraine selber
selbstbestimmt ihre entscheidungen
treffen sollen und ich habe das gefühl
sie haben ihre entscheidung getroffen
und ich glaube wenn der krieg morgen zu
gunsten von putin zu ende ist dann wird
die leute nicht besser gehen wir haben
schon bilder gesehen wie man wahllos
bürger und bürgern in der ukraine
einfach erschossen hat das bedeutet die
menschen vor ort haben entschieden wie
wollen widerstand leisten und das
mindeste was eine europäische land wie
deutschland die auch eine historische
verantwortung hat tun kann es waffen zu
liefern und dass deshalb verstehe ich
nicht warum diese waffenlieferungen
jetzt von ihnen in frage gestellt wird
das bedeutet wenn wir das nicht tun die
leute werden sowieso sterben aber haben
nicht die fähigkeit sich zu verteidigen
das glaube ich nicht und es ist doch
normal deutschland tut sich nichts wir
haben die ukraine kommen um mich am
stärksten unterstützt ich weiß uns auch
jetzt militär ist ja gar nicht meine ja
gar nicht meine position aber
deutschland ist um uns von den
sanktionen am stärksten betroffenen
vermutlich und wir machen das ist auch
richtig so absolut und die
waffenlieferung finden ja stadt übrigens
auch mehr als mir persönlich sympathisch
ist aber ich will mal eines sagen da
findet mehr stand das öffentlich
behauptet wird dass wir nicht mehr so
publiziert weil man sorge hat wenn man
das auch noch alles ankündigt und
darstellt das denn die die waffen
transportieren dann auch wieder ein ziel
für die russen sind sozusagen weil die
land machen die geheiligte mitreißend
alias es spannend das heißt deutschland
liefert eigentlich mehr als wir bürger
gerade meinen was geliefert wird
das weiß ich sie wissen dass mehr
geliefert wird ja und wir werden darüber
ja auch im auswärtigen ausschuss
vertraulich unterrichtet was da passiert
und ausschüssen auch aber die
bundesregierung hat sich entschieden
darüber öffentlich nicht wieviel märz
darüber will ich nicht reden
und ich sag mal ist auch etwas anderes
was der ukrainische botschafter und ich
hier sagt was die regierungsvertreter
der ukraine mit denen scholz
telefonieren mit selen ski fast jeden
tag da ist man ständig in in
verhandlungen darüber dass das passiert
und auch wenn es nicht meine position
ist aber zu üben schon zur kenntnis
nehmen die bundesregierung hat sich
entschieden auch frau berbalk wie man es
eine fabelhafte figur macht aus meiner
sicht haben sich entschieden
deutlich mehr zu machen und trotzdem
weil sie sagen die ukraine muss das
selbst entscheiden sage ich ja auch
manche dinge wird man nicht tun können
diese wollen auch eine luft
flugverbotszone machen das kann man
nicht machen weil dann die nato
involviert werde deswegen macht
deutschland nicht alles was gefordert
wird aber was die waffen angeht die wir
jedenfalls haben und abgeben können die
werden auch geliefert aber es wird nicht
mehr kompliziert weil man das nicht
gefährden will denn die müssen geschützt
werden diese transporte man muss ja
nicht wissen wann aber darf der bürger
nicht erfahren wie viele waffen
geliefert werden welches wohl die
aussage der bundesregierung ist dass wir
das immer zu dem zeitpunkt jetzt machen
wenn die waffen angekommen sind abholen
nicht vor aber es ist einiges in der
pipeline will ich mal vorsichtig die
antwort ist zufrieden stellen
nicht sagen die regierung will waffen es
ist nicht zu
müssen ich bin nicht
verteidigungsminister in die haben das
würde ich auch dem verständnis das darf
man auch nicht tun das mache jetzt
abgeordnet aber das ist doch eigentlich
eine gute botschaft für die ukraine das
mehr waffen kommen denkt denn eigentlich
der ukraine jemand ans aufgeben
ich habe tatsächlich wieder in kiew noch
in den anderen städten in denen ich war
menschen getroffen was jetzt nicht
heißen soll dass es die nicht gibt
erstaunlicherweise was mich da am
meisten erstaunt hat ist das selbst
flüchtlinge die aus mario pohl kommen
also der stadt die ja wirklich am
meisten umkämpften 90 prozent der häuser
zerstört sind wo viele menschen anwohner
verwandte familie verloren haben dass
selbst diejenigen die dort menschen
verloren haben nicht sagen gibt jetzt
auf auch sehr interessant ist ja die
flucht bewegung sozusagen der menschen
dass mario pohl denn die wenigsten gehen
dort richtung russland und die meisten
gehen weiter richtung ukraine man muss
ja auch sagen dass die meisten
flüchtlinge weiterhin sozusagen im land
sind also dieser wille
der scheint ungebrochen was mich auch
tatsächlich überrascht muss ich sagen
ich hätte gedacht je länger so ein
grausamer krieg
passiert
desto mehr menschen sterben dass das
auch bedeutet dass die menschen sagen
jetzt lasst uns etwas tun was diesen
krieg beendet aber ich glaube das liegt
sicherlich an der figur wladimir putin
den man einfach nicht vertrauen kann
viele menschen sagen aber was ist denn
wenn er jetzt damit sie längst gesetzt
und sagt okay ihr geht nicht in die nato
neutralität bestimmte gebiete nennen wir
anders bedeutet das dann dass der krieg
vorbei ist oder bedeutet ist dass
wladimir putin einfach zeit gewinnt
vielleicht wenn ein paar sanktionen
gelockert und er bringt seine armee
wieder auf vordermann und greift dann
wieder an das darf man ja man darf das
ja alles nicht vergessen dass für viele
menschen auch im osten eben dieser krieg
bereits 2014 dort ist viele anders als
in europa anders als in deutschland in
frankreich damit gerechnet haben dass es
zu dieser eskalation kommen könnte und
das sorgt natürlich psychologisch für
etwas ich finde werde ich das noch sagen
darf die aussage die bundesregierung
erzählt jetzt nicht mehr wie viele
waffen sie liefert weil wir tun so
wahnsinnig viel deswegen können wir das
gar nicht erzählen die finde ich gut
laufen die sendung nicht
ändern lassen